قابليه الترشح للرئاسه وسيد للبيت الابيض
مودان تساؤلات رماديه بالمجهوله الاجوبه
تقطع حتى اللحظه للتفسير والتاويلات
فامكانيه اكمال رحله التنفس للعوده للبيت
الابيض باتت موضعه تساؤل ما هو مصير
دونالد ترامب السياسي هل لا يزال بامكانه
الترشح للرئاسه وهل يستطيع البقاء في
البيت الابيض ان ادين محللون وصفوا الازمه
الحاليه
بالدستوريه من اعلى مستوى حتى اكبر من
قضيه ووتر غيت وفق تعبيرهم حاليا لا يوجد
موانع لاستكمال حمله ترامب الرئاسيه او
المشاركه وحتى الفوز في الانتخابات كونه
لا يزال غير مدان فالمحاكمه لا تخرجه
تلقائيا من حمله الرئاسه على الاقل
قانونيا اما شعبيا فيمكن ان تضر التحقيقات
والجلسات بحظوظه في الفوز او قد تكون
دعايه ناجحه اما ثاني التساؤلات هل يحق
ترامب ان يصبح رئيسا في حاله الادانه
اصدار حكم سواء البراءه او الادانه قد
يتاخر الى ما بعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه
الامريكيه المقبله والمقرره طبعا في
نوفمبر 202 حينها اذا اذن ترامب سيواجه
خيار الذهاب الى السجن الى السجن او دفع
غرامه او الحصول على حكم مع وقف التنفيذ
وبالتالي يصبح اول رئيس امريكي يتعرض
للادانه او الحكم بالسجن لكن هذا لا يعني
بالضروره خروجه تلقائيا من سباق الرئاسه
بمجرد الادانه او انه سيترك المكتبه
البيضاوي في حال صدر الحكم بعد فوزه في
الانتخابات مجله نفت وجود اجابه واضحه
لذلك في الدستور الامريكي فهو لا
فقره تمنع صراحه انتخاب رئيس مدام بجريمه
او تمنع انتخاب رئيس وهو داخل السجن كما
ان انتخاب رئيس لا يلغي التهم المرفوعه
ضده
ولا يخرجه من السجن في حال كان دخله قبل
الانتخابات